I love what you two are doing with this
house but what are you gonna do with
five bedrooms you guys are obviously
never having kids
what was that look I did not do a look
you're doing a look right now there's no
look I have a good fight guys there's so
many kids in foster care and they're
having an orientation value people who
take in foster kids are really special
the kind of people who volunteer when
it's not even a holiday we don't even
volunteer on a holiday over a half
million children are currently in foster
care the county put C's on because they
can match a lot of kids and parents
quickly look at their teenagers okay
maybe's drugs and they watch people
playing video games on YouTube they're
not equipped for any of that are you
this fYI we can all hear you hmm
okay well mingle with the kiddies and
don't give it another thought
bye bye she was cool Lizzy comes with
two younger siblings three kids too much
oh my God why would you show us that
that's wrong Helia
make yourself at home because you're at
home dealing Cooper saw more of a Lakers
fan the Clippers are awesome they were
smart for trading Blake Griffin their
best player data to the fire department
comes okay here's just another white
lady who wants to adopt charity orphans
make you feel good about your spouse ten
we might have a little bit of a knack
for this
yeah I beg to differ this stuff takes
time busy the parent wanted Lita all by
herself this is never going to be easy
but with some structure and love you
could make your house
we love you please go away I don't piss
do you know what I'd like to do
alright let me fix it okay got my first
baby suck hey honey can I help you with
anything what are you doing in my phone
looking with this boy texted her based
on the picture you set for a cake no
look I'll end your life right now carrot
top we're gonna call your mom you're
going down to tango what do you think of
that chicken
my name is on Jacob what okay
[Music]